the Joe Rogan experience [ __ ] this
the lady who said that uh Biden did
something to her now she's saying it was
sexual assault yeah well they're gonna
digging if they're smart they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna swap Biden
out well he's kind of a meatball but
he's a better candidate than Biden but
this shows the hypocrisy of liberals
that they're not coming after him they
want they want him to be the
representative of the Democratic Party
but here's the thing they are right now
they were wrong before like here's why
they're right now and they were wrong
before anybody could comment anybody
with an allegation where anybody could
come at any how high-profile when you
say believe all women you have to live
by them you gotta believe Amber Heard
you gotta believe every pot yeah you
gotta believe everybody seen all this
Johnny Depp [ __ ]
I saw a little bit of it yeah Jesus
Christ there's audio tape yeah what
she's talking about hitting him yeah and
then there's a new video where it shows
his severed finger she threw a [ __ ]
vodka bottle on it she was that slice
tip of his finger literally these
pictures of the finger and there's the
dot they've the audio recordings of the
doctor looking for the fingertip they're
looking for the tip they can't find the
tip like where's the [ __ ] fingertip
and the ring oh my god look at the blood
and you can hear them talking and she's
like violently sobbing in the background
so they decide to give her three times
whatever antipsychotic medicine there
aren't that she's on so she's on this
this dose they decide to jack it up to
3x whatever the doses but meanwhile this
was the lay that had him me to Dan was
saying that he beat her and leave had a
mark on her face leave all women well
that's the whole thing so the Democrats
are now reaping what they've sown in the
sense that anybody can can approach
something you know the press with an
unsubstantiated allegation about
somebody who's high-profile I mean I
understand that women aren't just
willy-nilly lying about stuff but the
picture changes when there's somebody is
a politically divisive high-profile
figure where there is a huge incentive
to knock that person off right there's a
huge incentive whether it's Brett
Kavanaugh whether it's Joe Biden there's
a huge incentive to derail that person
so I think in that instance because I do
believe that like most women are not
just making things up that be
sad when you introduce politics there's
a whole nother level it's a whole nother
layer well for sure I mean the audience
agencies could be doing this too
yeah you know that could yeah I mean I'm
not saying this woman who actually
worked for Biden's campaign was a
foreign intelligence agent we have no
what I'm saying is that for sure men
have sexually assaulted women also for
sure women have lied about being
sexually assaulted those two things are
they they're not mutually exclusive they
go hand-in-hand right people are liars
do people lie about the past hundred
percent people also are delusional
people are also psychotic and
schizophrenic yeah all sorts of things
are going on but this when you say
believe all women that is a crazy thing
to say believe that's like saying
believe all people correct it's the same
thing I can't just so what are you doing
you believe the liars - do you believe
murderers do you think people are trying
to get out of jail don't believe rapists
you can't believe all people right you
also can't believe all men well you also
can't believe all women that's crazy
talk you believe Casey Anthony no of
course what I do know she's the one that
I'd make an exception
she seems like a good kid humans are
individuals and some people are [ __ ]
crazy yeah I mean so he's I don't know
man but I think the bigger problem with
him is he's he is in some stage of
dementia dementia he's unwell there's
something he's unwell I swear he's a
folder either that or he may be just as
bad he folds under pressure he's very
close to the finish line he's just
bumbling all his words and choking and
forgetting what he's talking about I
don't think it's that I think
something's wrong because you know why
there it seems like it's degenerative
like it seems like it's gotten it's
getting worse
so that's why I think something's wrong
100% yeah also he's old as [ __ ] yeah
also he looks bad doesn't look like a
healthy guy no a second this weird lady
Gaga thing today with him and Lady gaga
where he's talking about how no one
should ever put their hand on a woman
who and I'm watching this with cuz I
guess Lady Gaga was sexually assaulted
but who the [ __ ] is ever going to watch
that and say you know what I was gonna
put my hand on a woman but now I'm not
gonna go back to that she looks like
go back down a story about oh okay she
has a Hillary haircut and that's an
interesting move Hillary yeah look at it
let me see it again it's actually old
because it's it's from 2017 Oh kind of
looks a little I was just coming out now
I guess people are throwing it around
now what were they saying
I don't know nonsense they here's the
thing
the they were saying no one should ever
put their hand on a woman of course they
shouldn't of course but if you're
thinking about hitting a woman and Joe
Biden is what keeps you from doing it
like what what I don't understand the
logic I said odd I guess maybe if you're
a woman who's being abused it could
perhaps encourage you to go to the
authorities right we couldn't perhaps I
mean right but I would imagine but by
saying by him saying no man should ever
put his hands on a woman who the [ __ ]
thinks they should who's like they'd not
disagree yeah man she just beat the [ __ ]
out of what I keep him in line somebody
saying somebody said once it's like when
somebody goes hey I'm pro-family it's
like that's a controversial position
you know I'm Pro fam right but all these
public service announcements all that
kind of [ __ ] it's like okay who are you
doing that for yeah like who's out there
going I was about to rape but then I saw
Joe Biden and he's like don't rape much
he's got a yeah yeah he's good and I
just respect them he's a statesman to do
well it's just that that's part of why
nobody believes anything and nobody
trusts anybody right that's part of why
these guys that are online are they go
hard in the paint with conspiracies
because these are buffoons like the
people that we have ruling us have been
exposed as like creations right now
these people everything they say
scripted you know all of them are are in
the pocket of big business interests and
like and and these people have been
exposed so now we don't believe anything
[Applause]